i've gained
quite a bit of weight uh like maybe even
like 15 pounds something like that since
i
moved to austin texas and i i still keep
the same diet
but i eat a lot of meat
in that one just because it's delicious
because it's also
the the amazing people i met in texas
it's just there's like a camaraderie a
friendship of love to the people that
like makes you really enjoy
the uh the atmosphere of eating the
brisket and the meat
is this joe rogan insisting joe is i
mean he's very different
uh joe loves bread
and pasta like he knows that his body
feels
best doing keto or carnivore
so that's what he usually tries to stick
to
but he also does not hold back and he'll
just eat pasta when he does pasta
and he sort of enjoys life in that way i
can't
i don't know how to enjoy life in that
way i also love pasta
but i'm just not going to enjoy it
because i know
i i know my body ultimately does not
feel good with pasta
so it's a funny kind of dichotomies i i
would
like to cheat i guess by eating more
meat than i you know like overeating
uh on the things that i know my body
feels good on as opposed to eating stuff
i shouldn't like cake and all those
kinds of things
i i tend to um i tend to find happiness
in overeating
the good stuff versus eating
the bad stuff and the that's the kind of
balance
him he's like [ __ ] it
every once in a while you gotta enjoy it
and and then also
coupled with that for him uh is
just exercise like then faces demons the
next day and just
like burn a huge amount of calories
which is i mean
whatever whatever is up with that guy's
mind
there's an there's a ability to fully
experience life which is represented by
the pasta
and the ability to just like fight the
demons which is represented by all the
crazy kettlebells and
and running the hills and all this kind
of stuff that he does that takes a lot
out of you doing that kind of insane
exercise and i think i'm more like you
or at least towards your direction is
like i really hate exercise
so i do it but i really hate it and so
it's a balance that you have to strike
you